but first tonight it is full-scale war
between President Trump and a man who
just months ago was seen as one of his
closest allies and advisors indeed his
chief strategist yesterday Trump said
that Steve Bannon had quote lost his
mind after being canned for the White
House back in August now the president
is issuing legal threats against Bannon
Ben got a letter from Trump's legal team
on Wednesday threatening a lawsuit for
alleged violations of a confidentiality
agreement he apparently signed what to
make of all of this well a lot of people
claim to be experts on Trump and the
Trump White House the Trump orbit very
few of them really are Roger stone
actually is he's been advising Trump for
more than three decades he lobbied for
him in the 1990s he was campaign manager
of his aborted 2000 presidential run
stone was one of the people who strongly
urged the President to run for office
this time and he served on the campaign
during its critical or early months
Trump has fired stone more than once
maybe a bunch of times called him a
stone-cold loser but their relationship
has always recovered if anyone can truly
claim to understand that the president I
think it would be Roger stone so he
joins us tonight to explain Roger thanks
for coming on Thank You Tucker so what
is this fundamentally about it appears
to be from an outsider's perspective it
appears to be a debate about who can
take credit for the unexpected win in
2016 Steve Bannon has taken a lot of
credit for that publicly and privately
the president of course believes he did
it to what extent did Bannon contribute
to the victory well I wanted to give
Steve been and the benefit of the doubt
particularly given the reputation of
Michael Wolff for fabrication but now
that all the facts appear to be in and
the fact that these comments were made
while Steve Benton was working for the
president in the White House it's a it's
a stunning act of betrayal
and it's also a complete
misunderstanding of Donald Trump in
Donald Trump's world in Trump world
there is no Karl Rove there never has
been there never will be Donald Trump is
very much his own man he is his own
strategist he is his own phrase maker he
is his own speechwriter sometimes as
he's
his own press secretary he may be the
greatest single salesman in American
history and the President's agenda on
which he was elected I should say his
platform was determined long before
Steve Bannon
joined the campaign and was determined
by one man Donald Trump so this is a
phenomena he's a force of nature but he
cannot be handled or managed he's not a
puppet and he never will be so Bannon
argues that he put Trump's impulses
within a framework that allowed him to
win
I know Bannon from another life when we
ran rival publications I can't assess
his skill as a political strategist or
advisor is he a political genius in
campaigns or no no I would I would
actually argue that it's Donald Trump
who's the political genius here's
somebody who overcame enormous odds
massively outspent
with the opposition of the mainstream
media and scores one of the great upset
come-from-behind victories in American
political history now the Trump platform
was well settled on long before Steve
Ben and joined the campaign and it
appears that Stephen Miller helped the
president articulate it but the agenda
is Trump the drive to win is Trump the
populist campaign is all a Donald Trump
just taking the title of chief
strategist as a misnomer at best so the
idea was his but the idea was that after
the campaign Bannon was was kind of the
living conscience of the White House the
reminder of what the campaign was about
and a leader of this movement this
conservative movement why have so few
conservatives publicly defended Steve
ban in the last 24 hours
he's being attacked budge Rush Limbaugh
both attacked him today why is that well
first of all the movement is bigger than
any one person I asked six people on the
way in to the Fox to do here who Steve
Benton is and none of them knew every
single one of them knew who Donald Trump
was and every one of them knew about his
efforts to make America great again but
then you get to the specifics No
Donald Trump juniors meeting with a
woman Russian lawyer was not treasonous
it was not illegal it wasn't improper
steve is neither a lawyer nor an
experienced political strategist that
meeting is a nothing burger
it looks more and more like a setup to
me given the fact that the Russian woman
lawyer was in the country illegally at
the sufferance of the Obama
administration so I don't really
understand what would motivate Steve to
say these things when it's the president
who's given him the opportunity for high
public service when it's the president
who's given him a White House office you
could just see anger well but you could
chalk it up to anger over being fired if
he'd made these comments after he was
terminated but based on my research he
said these things while he was on the
Trump a role it's it sounds that way so
far so finally why the legal threats
does that I mean I don't think anyone
believes the president's gonna sue Steve
Bannon for violating an NDA or the
author of this book doesn't this just
call attention to the book help sell
books were down to the benefit of the
author of the book why would why would
you instruct your lawyers to do
something like that
yeah I'm not I'm not sure about the
efficacy of that I do know this that the
the Trump constituency the Trump base
will stick with Donald Trump as long as
he keeps faith with them on his agenda
the biggest tax cut in American history
a a solid conservative on the US Supreme
Court cutting regulations at all levels
that's the Trump agenda that is my new
phrase Roger it's great to see you
thanks for coming on tonight great to be
here Tucker many thanks